like if we were to go out and cancel all
of the odious debt and we'd have to
Define it somehow it's not like all the
debts odious but clearly the debt that
was lent to mabutu and Marcos and
suharto was odious you'd of course have
to have some sort of wine because I
Libertarians would argue that you know
money that democracies has borrow is
odious so you have to find a line but
maybe you could find a line and just say
like hey at least we all agree that like
this horrible dictator like those people
shouldn't have to pay that ironically
the US did it with Iraq after we invade
it um but like that's an exception we
usually don't allow that so that would
help certainly if you were to actually
write off debt the problem is is that
would shrink our banking system so we
don't have any incentive to do that